[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم اقدم اليكم حلقه جديده من برنامجكم
الذاكره السياسيه نتابع فيها مع الدكتور
خليل الدليمي رئيس هيئه الدفاع سابقا عن
الرئيس العراقي الاسبق صدام حسين اهلا بكم
معنا دكتور في هذه الحلقه ايضا
هل سمعت من الرئيس الاسبق صدام حسين عن
شعوره عندما
انزل تمثالها او نصبه من ساحه الفردوس
اخبرني بعد ان قات الامريكان على
الجامعه من الطبول بعدها ذهب الى منطقه
المنصور ومن منطقه المنصور ذهب الى
المدينه الثوره او مدينه ما يسمى الان
مدينه صدر
ضيعوا يعني هنا فقده والمصور
فيقول انا يعني من ساحه التحرير شفت ناس
يعني يركضون مواطنين يركضون شباب وصبيه
وكبار فوقفت الحمايه لو واحد يعني سالوهم
قالوا لهم ليش تركضون قالوا لهم تمثال مال
صدام
فكان الرئيس يبعد يعني من 50 الى 100 متر
عن
[موسيقى]
النصب عن اسقاط عن اسقاط النصب يعني راى
ذلك امي عينه نعم نعم يعني قال هو النصب
يعني هم العراقيين خلوه لكن اني اللي يعني
كان متاثر
يعني العراقيين بعض اللي كانوا من
الجماهرين بهاي الطريقه اكيد كان
والنصب يعني يروح نصب بيجي نصب
شكليات ما ياثر لكن كان هو يعني على من
عنده
دكتور خليل الكثير من يعني مما اتى على
لسان الرئيس العراقي الاسبق صدام حسين
ونقله لك في جلساتك الطويله معه ما يعتبر
ايضا يعني مذكرات صدام حسين نفسه قبل ان
تكتب ايضا في كتاب اخر مذكراتك الشخصيه
حضرتك ولكن ضمنت ذلك او جزء كبير من ذلك
في كتابك الاول هذا ما حدث لماذا قال لك
صدام حسين لماذا لا تحاسب امريكا ايران بل
تحاسبنا نحن في موضوع حلبجه تحديدا
الرئيس صدام حسين الله يرحمه وكل القيادات
العربيه الان يعني مدركين انه هناك تعاون
استراتيجي ما بين امريكا وايران وحتى
اسرائيل
هدفهم يعني كل هاي الدول هدفهم العرب
وهدفهم الامن القومي العربي للموقع
السياسي للموقع الجيو اقتصادي
بعيده المدى
ايران امريكا اعلنت بالثمانينات احتواء
المزدوج للعراق وايران احتوت العراق ودمرت
العراق اجت في التسعين ولكن لم تعمل شيء
تجاه ايران فكان واضح ومفهوم انه امريكا
حتى يعني
الشرع غزوها لانه من الدوله ما تسمح لها
ما صدر قرار فلجت وين المجلس النواب
الامريكي او الكونجرس الامريكي
بدات تطلع موضوع اسلحه الدمار شامل وموضوع
حلبشه ضرب حلبشه وموضوع اخر الحريات
والديمقراطيه وما الى ذلك
عندما احتل العراق وبحثت
بحثت هذه الجيوش من الفرق عن اسلحه دمار
الشامل لم تجد وحمله الانفال
موضوع الانفال يعني
كان في زمن يعني في حدود 88 او 89 88 نعم
كانت ايران ايضا متدخله الى حد الماء
بالمناطق الشمال
وكانت ايضا قضيه مفتوحه في المحكمه موضوع
الانفال ودافع نفسه والشعب العراقي والشعب
العربي اسمها انه الرئيس كان في موضوع
الكيمياوي وما الى ذلك هو ماذا قال لك في
هذا الامر تحديدا هو يؤكد انه لم نستخدم
الغاز الكيميائي لا بحلبشه ولا بالانفال
حتى بالهجوم على الفاويه يتهم الامريكيين
بانهم هم من حرضوا الايرانيين على الفور
كانت الاقمار الصناعيه تستكشف
مواقع القطعات العراقيه فهي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اعطت ثغره تتصور للقوات
العراقيه للقوات الايرانيه ان هناك ثغره
ايران عندما هجا هاجمت على الفاو احتلت
الفاو كانت بنصيحه وصور ومعلومات امريكيه
مئه في المئه دكتور خليل التحضيرات
العسكريه العراقيه للغزو الامريكي وكيفيه
تقسيم المناطق والقيادات وفقا لما اخبرك
به الرئيس العراقي الراحل صدام حسين شخصيا
في المعتقل
في كل حرب يتم تقسيم المهام ويتم تقسيم
الارض علاقه قطاعات
العراق قام بتقسيم حسب ما اخبرنا الرئيس
بتقسيمها الى يعني اربع قطعات او اربع
مناطق وخلى القياده هاي المناطق مع كل
قائد عسكري قائد سياسي
اطلاق الاوامر من عنده
فحسب التقسيم اللي حضرتك اطلعت عليه نعم
شمال الوسط الجنوب قسمين القاطع الغربي
وكلها الها قياده ضمن مناطق القتال
الميداني بس كنت تفهم منه انه كان يعتقد
انه في جهوزيه عند القوات العراقيه لكي
تقاوم ليس امام يعني ما في خيار اخر امام
القوات العراقيه او القائد العراقي الا ان
تقاتل
يعني ما ممكن تستسلم يعني تقاتل بالقوات
الممكنه مع فارق يعني فارق القوه يعني
الفرق ميزان القوى بماذا اخبرك الرئيس
العراقي الراحل عن قتاله شخصيا في شوارع
بغداد القوات الامريكيه وماذا حقق في ذلك
اخبرني انه عند جامعه ام الطبول اعطى
الدبابتين امريكيه
واعترض على هذا السلاح العربي المحمول على
الكتف واعترض المرحوم الطاهر في رمضان
على الرئيس قال هذا التصرفك يعني ما يعني
انت قائد انت مو جندي حتى تقاتل
وبعدها انه لازم تبقى يعني
اوامر وليس ان تترك نفسك لتصاب او تقتل
بالضبط ممكن جندي امريكي
اختل ميزان المعركه
وكيف كانت يومياته يعني كيف كان يقضي
يومياته الاولى بعد سقوط بغداد في التاسع
من ابريل
فيه يعني بعد ان اجتمع مع مع بعض القيادات
يوم 11 وقال لهم يعني الان القتال بالسلاح
الخفيف
استعدوا للقتال بسلاح الخفيف
ويوم 11 اخبرني انه طلب من حمايتهم
مرافقيه الذهاب يعني كل سبيل حاله وابقى
عناصر بسيطه جدا واتجه الى مدينه الرمادي
وتحديدا الى عند عائله الخربيط العربيه
الشيخ مظهر الشيخ نعم وحصل مع حصل الدكتور
خليل هل تحدث لك عن خيانات في صفوف القوات
المسلحه
اكدوا انا اكد لم تكن خيانه في الصفوف في
القيادات الاولى ولا القيادات للصف الثاني
على الاطلاق القاده العراقيين قاده كلهم
ابناء عشائر سواء من الشمال او الجنوب او
الوسط او مناطق الغربيه وعندهم يقاتلون
بعقيده عسكريه عراقيه مبنيه على مبدا
والعراق مبتدا عليه فلا اكد لا خيانه لا
في الصف الاول القياده العسكريه ولا في
الصف الثاني وما حصل هو تسريب لبعض يعني
الجنود
والقوه دائما يعني تبنى على يعني الجنود
صعودا بس كيف فسر لك صدام حسين سقوط
النظام بهذه السرعه
ودخول يعني احتمال الاحتلال بسرعه عدم
تكافؤ القوه يعني القوات العراقيه كانت
تقاتل بدون غطاء جويه
ولا حربي
الفرق شاسع جدا بين سلاح الامريكي والسلاح
العراقي المتهالك العراق محاصر ايضا منذ
1990 يعني 13 سنه محاصر فامر طبيعي ودقات
القوه عظمى معها اربعين دوله يعني اكيد
الموضوع مختلف تماما هذه الاسباب التي
قالها لك والسبب الاخر استخدام امريكا
للسلاح النووي التكتيكي
في بغداد ولد صدمه يعني عندما الجندي
العراقي يشوف الدبابه تنصهر امامه وتتحول
الى سائل
وهول الضربه يعني ولد يعني الى يعني
تداعياته هل تاكدت دكتور خليل من الرئيس
العراقي الاسبق بخصوص المعركه التي
تحدثت معلومات انه قتل فيها
الفاع عنصر من القوات الامريكيه ولكن هناك
معلومات تقول ان القوات الامريكيه غطت على
هذا الموضوع وان الرئيس العراقي الاسبق
كان مشاركا في هذه العمليات نعم اخبرني
مشاركه فعاله من قبل في هذه المعركه معركه
المطار
واشترك ايضا هو طبعا سلاح الارمي
واكد في احد المرات
كان يعني
اثناء زيارتي له
قبل الجلوس كنا واقفين انا الرئيس الله
يرحمه
والجنرال
الامريكي واليام ستيل فصار حديث يعني
سالني كيف الوضع قلت له يعني الامريكان
سلموا العراق الايراني فكان عصبي وكان
يحكي جنرال قال له اتحداكم تعلنوا عن
الشعب الامريكي وللعالم ان تعلنه عن
خسائركم اللي بلغت اكثر من 2000 جندي
ماريز من خيره القوات قتلتهم القوات
العراقيه خلال معركه المطار خلال معركه
المطار وطبعا ما جاوبوا هذا القائد بقى
ساكت وبعدين طلع
اين كان صدام حسين ليله الغزو
كان في بغداد
ولكن كان يعني ترك القصر طبعا خارج القصر
هو كان في المزرعه وعندما يعني قصفت
المزرعه قبل قصفها
بدقائق خرج منها
اين كان عند سقوط بغداد
يوم عشره
انتقل من شارع المطار الى المنصور الى
ثوره وطلع في مدينه الثوره او مدينه الصدر
في منازل عراقيين مواطنين
وبعدها انتقل الى الاعظميه وهناك
الثقب المقاتلين العرب
التقى بالاهل الاعظميه واهل العظميه
معروفين ببطنيتهم
يعني
ضربت عليه
الاحاديه مال احد المدرعات الامريكيه ضربت
فانصاب بشضيه قال الاصابه كانت طفيفه
بعدها
انتقل الى منطقه خارج بغداد
وطلب من مرافقي التفرق وهو نزل بزورق وعبر
عن الضفه الثانيه واجا
محافظه الانبار الى بيت عائله الخربيط
وبعد ذلك
المفروض ان يبدا بالتخفي بعد ذلك
بعد ان القصف طلع الى منطقه هيت
ومن منطقه هيت انتقل الى محافظه صلاح
الدين وبدا من هناك يقود فصائل المقاومه
نتابع بعض الفاصل دكتور خليل شكرا لوجودك
معنا مشاهدينا الكرام فاصل قصير قبل ان
نتابع ما لدينا في هذه الحلقه مع دكتور
خليل الدليمي رئيس هيئه الدفاع سابقا عن
الرئيس العراقي الراحل صدام حسين دعاهم في
اجتماع الى في مطعم الساعه
حال وصول الرئيس حسب ما ذكر لي انتبه الى
عدم وجود شخص لم يذكر اسم الشخص طلب من
عندهم الخروج من الاتجاهين من الجانبين
بعدهم يعني بالقرب من المطعم من قصف
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا مشاهدينا الكرام الى هذه
الحلقه من الذاكره السياسيه نتابع فيها مع
الدكتور خليل الدليمي رئيس هيئه الدفاع
سابقا عن الرئيس العراقي الراحل صدام حسين
اهلا بكم معنا دكتور مره جديده
قصه دعوه صدام حسين قياداته او بعض
قياداته بعد الغزو مباشره الى اجتماع في
احد المطاعم عندما تغيب عنه احد القيادات
المهمه جدا
ليكتشف صدام حسين خدعه او ان البعض قد
خانه فعلا ما الذي حصل
طبعا سر
عدم قدره الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على
او القوات الامريكيه او الاقمار الصناعه
على تحديد مكان رئيس هو استخدام لاماكن
بديله
فاحد هذه الاماكن البديله اللي يضطر اثناء
الحرب يجتمع فيها حكى لي دعاهم في اجتماع
الى في مطعم الساعه
وحال وصول الرئيس حسب ما ذكر لي انتبه الى
عدم وجود شخص لم يذكر اسم الشخص طلب من
عندهم الخروج من الاتجاهين من الجانبين
بعدهم يعني بالقرب من المطعم من قصف قامت
الطائرات بالاصفر هل عرفت من كان ذلك
الشخص لم يحدثني عنه لم يذكر اسم الشخص لم
يذكر لا تصريح ولا تلميح
هل قال لك من يتوقع ان يكون قد كشف موقعه
عند ال الخربيط
[موسيقى]
يعني حمل المسؤوليه لاستخدام الشباب
الموجودين مع الاسر والعوائل لاستخدام
الثريا يعني لا يمكن ان يكون موضوع يعني
خيالي وانما استخدام الثريه تحدد من قبل
الاقمار الصناعيه الامريكيه استخدام
الثريا عاده في يعني معروف عنها امنيا
يعني يستخدم بسياره سيرمالايقل عن 90 كيلو
متر بالساعه ومن ثم ترمى يعني بعدها
يخلص يعني او يتحدث يتصل لازم يرميها
ويتركها
فالثريات هي اللي كشفت وجود القوات وجوده
للقوات الامريكيه هل
انا الاوان لكي تكشف عن بعض الاسماء التي
لم تذكرها في كتابك بخصوص بعض المقربين
القيادات المقربه من الرئيس التي كانت
تمنع او تحجب عنه وصول بعض المعلومات من
مسؤولين عرب
فيها وسطات ومبادرات ومعلومات مهمه كانت
لربما انقذت العراق والعراقيين
التقيت يعني اغلب الوزراء او القيادات
العليا في الدوله في المعتقل وخارج
المعتقل ايضا بعد خروجهم كانوا يرمون يعني
بالحجه انه الرئيس ما كان يسمع كل شيء
والرئيس حرم من يعني كل المعلومات اللي
كان يجب ان يسمعها من القيادات العسكريه
عن وضع عمليه الدفاع حجم القوات العسكريه
الفرق الشاسع او الهاء بين عدم تكافل
القوتين بين القوات الامريكيه والقوات
العراقيه حسب ما هم نقلوا لي يعني سمعت
منهم انه كان الرئيس يفترض ان يسمعها
الرئيس في احد
اللقاءات حدثته
عن واقع معين حصلت
نفى علم بهذه الحادثه فاتذكر يعني بالحرف
الواحد قال اني يعني
حادثه معينه صارت يعني معينه حادثه
شخص مسؤول كان بالدوله العراقيه وتم سجنه
فاثار هذا الموضوع حفيظه لدى عشيرته
وقبيلته فنفع علم بها واكد لي انه يعني
اني مو كل شيء ادري به
قيادي كبير
يسجن في ظل نظام صدام حسين والرئيس لا
يعلم قال كان قيادي من مو سجن كان قيادي
من
المستوى المتوسط
فنفع علم به فاكد لي انه انا ما ادري يعني
كل شيء اني يوصلني اي موضوع معين اعالجه
على طول وذكر لي حاله معينه بالبصره قال
كان كانت قضيه معروضه على القضاء وكان احد
المسؤولين الكبار يتوسط لل
منحى الحريه القضيه قال فاتصلت الساعه
2:00 بالوزير وزير العدل
وطلبت من عنده ان يحضر جلسه المحاكمه
قالوا واخذت النتيجه
كانت يعني منه هو الذي كان يعين هؤلاء
المسؤولين الكبار وبالتالي يعني هناك
معلومات تتحدث عن حجب معلومات عنه بتلك
الاهميه هل يمكن ان نعرف طيب انت لا تريد
ان تذكر اسماء ولكن كيف تصف هاتين
الشخصيتين يعني اغلبهم
توفاهم الله يعني بصيغه او اخرى فما اريد
ان ندخل اقرب المقربين الى الرئيس احدهم
الى اقرب المقربين نعم وهذه كانت خيانه
هذا ما سمعته اني يعني اني ما كنت بالدوله
هذا ما سمعته من الوزراء ومن قاده عسكريين
انه كان بدنا ان نقول للرئيس عن بعض
التفاصيل اللي ممكن قد يستفاد من الرئيس
لكن كنا ننصح انه ما نقول لشيء من باب عدم
ازعاج الرئيس او عدم يعني
انت يعني فهمت منهم انه كان لهذه لهائتين
الشخصيتين مارب اخرى اهداف اخرى غير موضوع
ازعاج الرئيس والى ما هنالك لم يذكروا
ماذا سمعت منه عن لقاءاته بعزه الدوري
نائب رئيس مجلس قياده الثوره قبل الغزو
كان يلتقي بشكل طبيعي يعني يلتقي بالقياده
ويلتقي بالمرحوم بقصد اللقب اللقب قبل
الغزو بس انه بعد الغزو بعد الغزو كم مره
التقي وياه مره واحده
ومعهم قياده اخر في محافظه صلاح الدين
في مكان يعني
في مكان يعني مو بعيد عن يعني
شيء بسيط عن المكان اللي القي القبض عليه
وكان معهم قياده اخر
ليس بعيدا عن المكان
موعد اللقاء بعد المغرب يعني
بعد العشاء
ما الذي دار في هذا اللقاء يعني على ما
تحدثان اعتقد على التنظيم المقاومه عمل
التنظيم المقاومه والمتابعتها
واستطاع ان يظل على تواصل لاحقا عن طريق
المرافقين بس تقول انه قبل اعتقالهم
مباشره لا بعد بعد اعتقاله العفو قبل اعتق
يعني اللقاء الاول والاخير بعد الغزو
يعني قبل اعتقال قبل اعتقال الراحل صدام
حسين بقليل جدا كيف ظل التواصل يعني وهو
في المعتقل لا وتواصلوا قبل الاعتقال وبقع
التواصل يعني مع التوجيهات توصل
للمرحوم عزت ابراهيم
سواء للي التقطها عن طريق المحاكمات
مباشره او عن طريق المحامين
اذا يعني يمكن ان نسجل التاريخ بانك اسهمت
بشكل مباشر
باداره بعض عمليات المقاومه العراقيه شرف
لهذه الادعاء
اذا ادعاء الحقيقي اذا كانت لي بصمه في
المقاومه العراقيه ويحق مشروع وبوش نفسه
الذي قاد الغزو العراق اعلن قال له احتلت
بلادي لقمت فاذا كان هذا القول يعني يرتب
لي شرف المشاركه في هذا الشرف لي
ومن خلال المعلومات التي تنقلها من صدام
حسين الى الخارج نعم
كان في معلومات هامه جدا تقول للتاريخ
بانه اثرت على الارض كنت تتابع تراقب
نتائج ذلك على الارض
بشكل كبير جدا
ترفع المعنويات وكانت
يعني بعض المعلومات انه يطلب من الانفصال
المقاومه الابتعاد عن الفصائل المتشدده
لانه هذه وراءها ما وراءها بالفعل اثبتت
الاحداث انه ايران وحتى امريكا وراء بعض
الفصائل المشدده اللي ممكن انه يعني
تسيطر على عمليات المقاومه وتظهرها بمظهر
مختلف
يعني كانت مدسوسه يعني قتل الناس وضرب
القوات الامريكيه وهي يعني موجوده اثناء
بها بالاسواق او اللي راح ترضى القوات
الامريكيه وتوقع اكثر الخسائر مفهوم ولكن
صدام حسين لم يتوقع الغزو على ما يبدو كما
حصل يعني توقع ضربات مثل 91
او اكثر بقليل ولكن ليس بالحجم والطريقه
اللي حصل فيها
انا سالته قال احنا الدولي
ولا يمكن ان يسمح المحيط الدولي او العامل
الدولي بانفراد امريكا بهذا بما حصل موجود
الحاسوب موجود العفو روسيا موجوده فرنسا
موجود الصين فلا يمكن ان يسمحوا لامريكا
بالاستحواذ على العراق فكان يتوقع ضربات
يعني ضربات قصف بغداد
واحتلال لمناطق وقصبات قريبه على الحدود
اما بالشكل اللي حصل لا ما كان يعني
الا بحسابات بسيطه جدا من وشها بصدام حسين
الجانب الامريكي هذا الموضوع طبعا حساس
جدا والى تداعياته
انا يعني في اكثر اللقاءات التلفزيونيه
دائما احاول يعني هذا الموضوع اخذه
يعني اراده كما يعني انا ناقل فيه
الامريكان رورو روايتهم والرئيس ردا على
الروايه الامريكيه كتب رساله
حدود عملي كان ابلغ الرساله لمن يعني هم
الامر فقمنا بنشر الرساله وسائل الاعلام
وبلغت انه الرئيس الله يرحمه كتب هاي
رساله وحدد اشخاص معينين انا من الناحيه
الشخصيه
لا اتبنى روايتين الشعب العراقي
واقرباء الرئيس وعائله الرئيس يعرفونه حقا
من الذي وشاب الرئيس فالي من باب جبل
الشرع النفسي او جب الشك وشبهات عن نفسي
انقل الروايتين والشعب العراقي
والمعنيين هم اللي يحددون ما فهمت من بعض
المصادر انه
تخلخلت روايه الروايه التي كان يقتنع بها
الرئيس وذكرته بكتابك حضرتك بانه قيس
النامق واخوانهم الذين وشوا به هذا مو انا
اللي ذكرته برساله انه هو
نعم هو اللي قال حدد الاسماء بس انا
بالمجمل الاحداث ما اتبنى اي من روايتين
هاي روايه الرئيس والشعب يقيمها والمعنينه
يقيمونها وهاي روايه الامريكان وهم ايضا
ولكن بالتاكيد في روايات اخرى عن اشخاص
اخرين قد يكونوا هم من فعلوها يعني هذا
الامر متروك القادم السنين او قادم الاشهر
او قادم الايام ولا المعنيين الحقيقيين هم
اللي يقدرون هذا من خلال التحقيق مع
الاطراف المعنيه مع المرافقين اللي كانوا
مع الرئيس مع اخر شخص بقى مع الرئيس
واكيد يعني يوصلون الى نتيجه السؤال
الاخير
عائله الرئيس الراحل تعلم يعلمون حق
المعرفه بشخص الحقيقي بالشخص الحقيقي اللي
هم متاكدين انهم هو اللي وصى فيه بكل
تاكيد ولكن الجميع يجمع الى انه يعني هذا
الوقت مو وقته لانه اغلب يعني الناس
العراقيين يعني
[موسيقى]
يعيشون في اسقاء الدول مشردين ف مو وقتها
ولكنه كان قريب منه
او قريب لقريب منه هذا متروك لهم هم
يحددون
شكرا جزيلا لوجودك معنا في هذه الحلقات
دكتور خليل الدليمي نتابع في بدايه الحلقه
المقبله مشاهدينا الكرام نتابع في بدايه
الحلقه المقبله مع الدكتور خليل الدليمي
رئيس هيئه الدفاع سابقا عن الرئيس العراقي
الاسبق صدام حسين
وسطوني حتى يقبل يعني اثناء
المحاكمه ورفض ووسطوني حتى يقابلوا وايضا
رفض بشده
ووسطوني حتى
يتكلموا معها يعني
بعد النطق بالحكم وايضا رفض وطلبوا من عند
الامريكان بيوم يعني قبل الاذان بساعات
انه يتحدث مع عائلته واضافه
[موسيقى]